[Applaudissements]
majesté altesse royale
mesdames et messieurs les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement
merci à mouhamadou d'oiry madame la
première ministre sheikh hasina et à
madame la vice présidente kamala harris
de s'être exprimé un instant mais merci
à tous les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement
ici présent d'être là je le dis avec
beaucoup de sincérité parce que
plusieurs d'entre vous venez de régions
connaissant aujourd'hui de très grandes
difficultés
qu'elles soient aux confins du continent
européen
au sahel au nord de l'afrique en asie en
amérique du sud et vous êtes là
montrant que ce dialogue se poursuit et
est indispensable
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
d'organisations non gouvernementales
chefs d'entreprise et entrepreneurs du
bien commun
mesdames et messieurs les organisateurs
du forum de paris pour la paix ce
président cher pascal cher justin chers
amis
je suis très heureux je vous le disais
de votre présence et de ce qui vient
d'être dit
par les uns et les autres chacun avec
son regard avec
l'expérience de son pays de ses valeurs
et je crois que c'est 100 dans ce
dialogue que peut justement se nourrir
une action utile
le forum de paris pour la paix
riesch à le rappeler tout à l'heure est
né le 11 novembre 2018 le jour du
centenaire de la fin de la première
guerre mondiale
en quelque sorte avec cette volonté de
tenir la promesse à leur fait plus
jamais cela
et à un moment même où nous vivions
collectivement une crise inédite du
multilatéralisme
des accords juste signé été remise en
cause
les organisations multilatérales
voyez certains de leurs membres éminents
s'éloigner
et donc nous avons collectivement
essayer de bâtir de nouvelles méthodes
chercher de nouveaux acteurs bâtir un
nouveau destin collectif en étant plus
efficaces ensemble
et grâce à vous toutes et tous nous
avons tenu durant ces années
et je dois dire madame la vice
présidente que de savoir les états unis
d'amérique revenant pleinement dans le
club du multilatéralisme fut pour nous
tous une formidable nouvelle
est donc merci pour cela
parce que je crois que c'est la place la
vocation des états unis d'amérique et
parce que je pense que pour nous tous
c'est aussi la condition d'une action
utile
néanmoins les enjeux demeurent
parfois plus inquiétant encore
aujourd'hui qu'hier
et il requiert de poursuivre sur le
chemin que nous avons essayé de tracer
pour tenter d'être plus efficaces et
d'avoir des résultats
je crois comme vous au multilatéralisme
je l' ai dit à plusieurs reprises mais
je crois au multilatéralisme efficace
et je crois que la difficulté de la
période que nous vivons est double
c'est que ce multilatéralisme a parfois
été trahi par certains qui en avaient
été les promoteurs et il a été fragilisé
il faut que nous leur donnions tous
ensemble plus de force
de légitimité
et dans le même temps nous nous sommes
collectivement habitués à une forme
d'inefficacité et je crois que c'est
d'ailleurs le drame de beaucoup de
démocratie
expliquez-moi votre problème je vous
expliquerai comment je ne peux pas
totalement y répondre en tout cas dans
un temps qui est humainement utiles pour
vous
et les crises se multipliant c'est la
légitimité même de nos réponses qui sont
roux va tech est donc redonné une force
multilatéralisme efficace c'est je crois
à bâtir des réponses concrètes avec de
nouveaux acteurs de nouvelles méthodes
de nouvelles formes de coalition et se
donnaient des rendez vous réguliers pour
voir où nous en sommes
c'est une méthode de coopération une
méthode qui associe les états les
entreprises les organisations
intergouvernementales les structures
régionales ici présente également les
ong les académiques les activistes pour
bâtir des coalitions d'acteurs comme la
coop cherche à le faire sur le climat
comme nous l'avons fait avec le one
planet ce mythe est comme tous les
porteurs de projets qui sont ici
présents le font pour des actions
éminemment importante pour lutter contre
nos grands défis je tiens à les en
remercier
alors je voudrais simplement me borner
dans ce propos à rendre compte de ce qui
a été fait sur les engagements pris il y
a un an ici même il y a un an nous
avions essayé de définir ce qu'on aurait
appelé ce consensus nouveau
internationale ce consensus de paris
faisant écho un consensus
de plusieurs décennies qui avait
structuré
un capitalisme financiarisé sur la
planète et qui avait mis en place des
doctrines qui avait été utile pour
lutter et sortir une partie d'ailleurs
continent de la pauvreté mais dont nous
voyons alors les limites ce consensus
que nous avions bâti nous avions
collectivement donner quelques objectifs
le premier aller au bout de la réponse
universelle de la réponse universelle à
la pandémie
vous y êtes toutes et tous revenus et
président boyrie vous avez décidé de
vous exprimer principalement sur ce
point
l'année dernière à la même époque
nous pensions avoir un vaccin
il était peut-être en train d'arriver
et nous avions d'ores et déjà construit
une action internationale avec
l'accélérateur
acta est l'initiative rappelé tout à
l'heure nous l'avons vu par le directeur
général de l'om est sûre tedros pour
lutter contre la pandémie
depuis un an
beaucoup de choses ont été faites dans
tous les pays développés pour vacciner
le maximum de la population mais en un
temps aussi nous avons su convaincre
collectivement les pays riches de
partager leurs vaccins et nous avons
largement dépassé le milliard de doses
initialement promise par le g7
la clé est maintenant d'aller jusqu'au
bout sur le terrain vous avez rappelé
des chiffres importants de madame la
vice présidente et je vous en remercie
au moment où je vous parle la france a
pu confier hier deux millions de doses
nouvelle via kovacs pour le bangladesh à
madame la première ministre mais
aujourd'hui d'ores et déjà les
françaises et les français ont chacun
livré une dose de vaccin au reste du
monde et nous aurons au premier
trimestre de l'année prochaine
livré une deuxième dose ce qui veut dire
que nous aurons dépassé l'objectif de
120 millions de doses données
néanmoins ces engagements du g7 du g20
ne sont pas suffisants
vous avez rappelé les chiffres avec
beaucoup de cruauté on vaccine dix fois
moins vite sur le continent africain
dans le pacifique dans les caraïbes dans
certaines régions d'asie
il nous faut donc aller beaucoup plus
vite et beaucoup plus fort premièrement
en accélérant les dons de doses pas
forcément les milliards qui viendront
dans un an deux ans cinq ans les dons de
doses
deuxièmement nous devons renforcer la
transparence sur ces dons de doses sous
l'égide de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé et pour que tout le monde sache
qui donne et où les choses vont
troisième point nous devons renforcer
les systèmes de santé dans les pays les
plus fragiles
en accroissant le partenariat avec
l'unicef qui est celui qui permet
justement d'accélérer la vaccination sur
le terrain
et nous devons aussi collectivement
réussir à bâtir une aide renforcée à
l'égard des systèmes de soins primaires
nous y travaillons et je remercie le
président michel d'être là avec
plusieurs chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne nous
y travaillons en vue du sommet entre
l'union africaine et l'union européenne
qui se tiendra en février prochain à
bruxelles et qui sera un moment
important de la concrétisation de cette
solidarité
mais nous devons et vous l'avez rappelé
aussi accélérer la production des moyens
de lutte contre les pandémies sur tous
les continents et c'est pourquoi la
priorité est aussi
de pouvoir produire des vaccins dans les
pays en voie de développement à revenu
intermédiaire et parfois les pays les
plus pauvres
au sénégal en afrique du sud au rwanda
les transferts de technologies
nécessaires ont déjà été actée pour
permettre l'augmentation des capacités
de production la côte d'ivoire est en
train d'y travailler et je sais que dans
les prochaines semaines nous aurons
aussi un résultat sur ce volet mais sur
ces sujets nous ne pouvons accepter une
situation je veux ici vous rappeler les
chiffres
ou le continent africain représente 20%
des besoins de vaccins quelles que
soient les épidémies et a une capacité
de production de 2%
il est en quelque sorte à chaque crise
la victime de restriction de priorité
nationale ou régionale mise par d'autres
régions du globe et donc il nous faut
dans la durée contre ce virus mais au
delà contre les autres virus pour
lesquels il existe de la vaccination
pour suivre ces transferts de
technologie et ses capacités de
production et nous devons tous adopté un
cadre de conduite claire pour tirer les
leçons de la pandémie nous en avons
discuté dans le cadre du g20
lever les restrictions aux exportations
qui nous ont tant bloqué au coeur de la
crise améliorer la transparence sur les
contrats d'approvisionnement en obtenant
un accord à l'om c'est pour que le
partage de la propriété intellectuelle
ne soit plus une entrave à l'accès
équitable et bâtir un mécanisme solide
de prévision et d'alerté précoce des
crises sous l'égide de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
chacun doit pour cela prendre ses
responsabilités mais si beaucoup a été
fait depuis un an pour lutter contre la
pandémie nous voyons tout ce qui nous
reste à faire et je cite elle a beaucoup
le continent africain dans le pacifique
les mêmes situations étaient connus nos
amis des balkans qui sont ici présents
ont aussi tant souffert de voir leur
pays privé de doses au moment où leurs
voisins à quelques kilomètres parce
qu'ils étaient dans l'union européenne
pouvaient en bénéficier
je crois que nous avons tous des leçons
à tirer de ce qu'est la véritable
solidarité des perspectives que vous
nous voulons leur offrir
le deuxième engagement que nous avions
pris c'est de réduire les inégalités
aggravée par la pandémie mais qui existe
au sein de nos pays et entre nos pays
vous l'avez rappelé avec beaucoup
d'éloquence madame la vice présidente
vous l'avez dit aussi madame le premier
ministre
c'est un chantier immense et c'est celui
qui fragilise notre organisation
internationale comme nos sociétés
occidentales
là aussi en un an à peine nous avons je
veux ici le rappelait beaucoup avancé
sur des sujets qui paraissait il y a un
an impossible il y a un an ici même nous
lancions le projet d'émettre des droits
de tirage spéciaux du fonds monétaire
international pour permettre justement
un accompagnement de la sortie de crise
grâce à l'engagement de la directrice
générale du fmi 650 milliards de droits
de tirage spéciaux étaient décidées
c'était il ya un an jour pour jour nous
appelons de nos voeux une solidarité
accrue au moins de mai dernier
beaucoup des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement africains ici présents
étaient là avec d'autres amis et nous
avons acté la nécessité de réallouer une
partie de ses droits de tirage spéciaux
des pays les plus riches vers les pays à
revenu intermédiaire et les pays en voie
de développement pour pouvoir justement
accompagner ce qui est aujourd'hui avant
tout une crise économique et sociale
liée à la pandémie
la part de l'afrique sur ses 650
milliards était de 33 milliards
nous avons donc porté ces initiatives
est actée en g20 la réallocation de 100
milliards de droits de tirage spéciaux
ce qui est le minimum minimorum que nous
pouvons et devons faire c'est celui qui
couvre un quart des besoins du continent
africain un tiers pardon des besoins du
continent africain sur la période 2021
2025 tels que chiffré par la banque
mondiale mais c'est un pas qui était
apparemment impossible il ya un an nous
l'avons fait et acter la france a décidé
de réallouer 20% de ses titres plusieurs
pays nous ont suivis et c'est ce qui
nous permet d'obtenir cet engagement des
100 milliards nous devons continuer de
travailler ensemble
et quelles que soient les techniques
adoptées par les pays vente de stock
d'or réallocation de leur droit de
tirage ce chiffre au minimum sera tenu
la mobilisation des moyens inédits pour
la solidarité internationale c'est une
avancée tangible vers une mondialisation
plus juste
et c'est ce même esprit cette même
volonté qui nous a permis une deuxième
grande avancée que vous avez rappelé et
qui était là aussi impossible à imaginer
il ya un an
une taxation des profits des
multinationales
et notamment des plateformes du
numérique au bénéfice de nos concitoyens
de tous pays cette taxation minimale qui
a été endossée en g20 à rome est une
avancée majeure pour l'égalité mondiale
pour autant
il nous reste là aussi de nombreux
chantiers
je ne pourrais pas tous les citer mais
nous savons qu'il nous faut aller plus
loin sur la mobilisation des droits de
tirage spéciaux nous savons qu'il nous
faut aller plus loin pour financer la
facilité est resté nous savons qu'il
nous faut aller plus loin aussi en
matière d'éducation
et je ne veux pas ici oubliez ce combat
vous l'avez rappelé la crise a privé
d'école pendant des mois un milliard et
demi de jeunes garçons et de jeunes
filles et l'unesco a chiffré les besoins
de sortie de crise au moins 11 millions
de jeunes filles ne retrouverait pas
l'école
principalement sur le continent africain
nous devons nous battre pour investir
davantage dans l'éducation qui est une
cause mondiale à l'unesco à
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie de manière bilatérale avec
les organisations régionales pour
répondre à ce qui est cette inégalité de
demain que nous subirons la pandémie le
terrorisme ont pour victimes nos enfants
et mes amis du sahel qui sont ici
présents le savent eux qui dans leur
pays subissent chaque jour des
fermetures d'écoles
à cause de cette politique de terreur
nous avons aussi sur le plan de la lutte
contre les inégalités
à continuer à nous battre sur le sujet
qui devient de plus en plus central de
la démographie mondiale
ce sujet dont les migrations ne sont
qu'une conséquence
doit nous conduire à réaménager nos
financements notre pensée même de notre
organisation internationale
nous ne pourrons durablement avoir un or
qui vieillit de plus en plus en bonne
santé et un sud qui fait de plus en plus
d'enfants avec si peu de perspectives
tout cela me créera que tension si nous
ne savons pas mettre au coeur de nos
politiques de développement de nos
investissements la question
démographique et les inégalités qu'elles
créent
le troisième axe que nous nous étions
donné l'année dernière pour de redéfinir
ce consensus
c'est évidemment nos engagements pour le
climat et la biodiversité
là non plus les mots ne suffisent plus
et les jeunesses de tous nos pays nous
appelle à faire plus demain la coop 26
se conclura et il ne reste que quelques
heures
alors je ne serai pas de ceux qui crient
victoire trop tôt
parce que nous n'y sommes pas encore
mais je ne suis pas non plus de ceux qui
veulent battre en retraite trop vite et
je pense qu'on décourage tout le monde à
dire à chaque fois qu'on est face à un
échec ou qu'il n'ya plus que des mots ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est plus vrai
mais il y a toujours et encore plus
d'engagement d'efficacité d'actions à
prendre et je veux ici adressé mon
ancien mon entier soutien aux
négociateurs à glasgow pour la dernière
ligne droite
une fois la coop terminée nous ferons le
bilan par rapport aux deux critères qui
comptent notre capacité collective à
éviter le réchauffement climatique
au-delà d'un degré et demi d'ici la fin
du siècle
et notre capacité collective à tenir nos
promesses en matière de justice
climatique les fameux 100 milliards de
dollars
pour aider les pays en voie de
développement à revenu intermédiaire et
les plus pauvres
mais d'ores et déjà
regardons ce qui a été possible et ce
qui a été fait ces derniers mois grâce à
l'engagement de tous ici présents
le g20 a pris il ya quelques jours
l'engagement historique d'arrêter d'ici
la fin de l'année tout financement
international de centrale à charbon
c'est une révolution qui est la
succession de décisions structurantes du
japon et de la corée du sud au printemps
dernier puis de la chine
l'engagement sur le méthane qui a été
pris à la coop pourrait s'il est
pleinement appliqué réduire le
réchauffement de 0,2 degrés celsius
nous avançons sur la prise en compte des
liens entre la préservation du climat et
la protection des écosystèmes comme nous
l'avons fait sur les forêts tropicales
comme nous continuerons de le faire au
travers de nos actions sur les océans
avec le sommet de février prochain et
sur la grande muraille verte scheer
président issoufou sur laquelle
plusieurs d'entre nous sommes
profondément engagé nous avons durant
cette dernière année réussi à re
synchronisée progressivement nos agendas
entre la lutte contre le réchauffement
et le dérèglement climatique et la lutte
pour la biodiversité combat
indispensable
ces derniers jours ont aussi été marquée
par une annonce sino américaines
importantes qui je l'espère marque le
début d' avancée qui viendront je le
rappelais à la tribune de glasgow ya
quelques jours
si les deux principales puissances ne se
mettent pas d'accord nous n'arrivons pas
à gagner ce combat
je salue les discussions à venir entre
le président aussi jean ping et le
président by donne et l'accord qui a
d'ores et déjà marqué une avancée à ce
point nous savons ce qui nous reste à
faire
1,5 degré pas plus à la fin du siècle la
neutralité carbone en 2050 des
stratégies nationales revue et réhaussée
pour 2030 pour tenir ses objectifs
l'union européenne
a pris ses engagements et les tiendra et
nous aurons dans les prochains mois avec
le green deal a acté
les mécanismes les financements
avec le président michel la présidente
chantal hay année l'ensemble des
collègues ici présent ce sont des
révolutions majeures
mais nous devons continuer d'aider
chaque pays à transformer en ce sens son
économie liée à cet égard
l'afrique du sud a montré un chemin un
chemin possible avec un appui technique
et financier de plusieurs d'entre nous
plusieurs organisations internationales
elle a acté une stratégie de sortie du
charbon par le nucléaire et les
renouvelables
permettant véritablement d'aller vers
une décarbonation de son économie ce qui
montre que pour les grands émergents
cette stratégie est aussi possible et
c'est ouvrir la voie à ce qui paraissait
jusque alors si peu crédible pour
certains
il nous reste pour autant des combats à
mener parfois dans les toutes prochaines
heures et les prochains jours nous
devons aller au bout du combat pour le
financement climatique et la finance
juste les 100 milliards de dollars par
an ne sont pas une option le rapport
rendu il ya quelques semaines montrent
que nous serons au rendez vous sur la
période 2020 2025
avec 100 milliards par an mais nous
avons un retard pour les quelques mois
qui viennent je sais tous les efforts
qui sont faits par votre administration
par vous même et le président biden pour
obtenir une majorité vous permettant de
rattraper en quelque sorte le retard des
dernières années et merci de ceux là je
pense que nous devons acte est de
continuer à innover las aussi et s'il
manquait quelques 2 milliards pour 2021
et 2022 de continuer l'innovation
financière avec le fonds monétaire
international et de les mobiliser par
des mécanismes supplémentaires à ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure des ventes
d'or des réallocations de droits de
tirage à nouveau nous n'avons pas le
droit d'attendre et de laisser attendre
les pays les plus pauvres
l'europe avec 27 milliards de dollars de
finances climat chaque année fait ça
juste par la france en son sein aussi
enfin sur le climat il nous faut
poursuivre sur les mécanismes de
transparence et de responsabilité
je me félicite que nous ayons pu lors de
cette coop finaliser ce que nous avions
lancée là aussi il ya un an pour
continuer de faire le suivi de nos
travaux communs un mécanisme de
responsabilité supervisé par le cdo
monsieur le secrétaire général
le mécanisme aipac va permettre et à l'
ocde d'évaluer chaque année les
stratégies climatiques menées par les
états et de voir si les actions sont au
rendez-vous des engagements c'est un
mécanisme de responsabilité
indispensable pour notre crédibilité
à l'égard de nos concitoyens et du reste
du monde
il nous faut poursuivre sur cette voie
et avoir un mécanisme de traçabilité et
de lisibilité sur la bonne affectation
des 100 milliards de dollars
sur la finance climatique de savoir qui
paye quand et où va l'argent car
aujourd'hui comme je le rappelais une
part non négligeable de ces 100
milliards par an va vers quelques grands
émergents mais trop peu vers certains
pays à revenu intermédiaire ou pays
pauvres nous avons donc encore des
engagements à tenir nous aurons dans les
mois qui viennent sur ces mécanismes de
responsabilité un travail essentiel et
nous aurons à poursuivre notre agenda en
matière de biodiversité avec le one shot
summit à brest avec les initiatives que
nous poursuivrons sur la grande muraille
verte lors du sommet entre l'union
africaine
et l'union européenne
enfin
le dernier grand défi que nous avions en
quelque sorte porter tous ensemble c'est
ce combat universel pour les droits et
les libertés pour nos valeurs
fondamentales
les valeurs de nos démocraties face aux
périls qui les menacent
c'était le quatrième grand engagements
pris l'année dernière
pour ce nouveau consensus
il n'est pas vrai que le le combat pour
les droits de l'homme seraient relatifs
à telle ou telle culture ou tel ensemble
géographique
je veux ici leur dire avec beaucoup de
force
les principes dont nous parlons
la dignité des femmes l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes la liberté
d'expression
la liberté de culte
la lutte contre toutes les formes de
xénophobie de racisme d'antisémitisme ne
sont pas des valeurs relatives aux
régionales elle sont universelles
c'est le fruit de nos combat existentiel
durant le xxème siècle
c'est parce que certains avaient accepté
des discours de faiblesse expliquant
qu'on pouvait dire non c'est
que nous avons connu le pire
nous n'avons pas le droit de répéter
cela
et donc
nos droits
les nôtres où que nous soyons
régresse à chaque fois que nous
détournons le regard et que nous cessons
de nous battre pour eux
se battre pour les droits de l'homme
c'est se battre pour les droits des
femmes partout comme nous l'avons fait
ensemble au forum génération égalité et
je veux remercier tous les acteurs de ce
forum
certains étant ici présents au travers
d' engagements concrets qui ont été pris
des financements massifs pour l'égalité
femmes hommes qui ont été annoncées lors
de ce forum 40 milliards d'engagements
nouveaux sur l'autonomisation des femmes
les engagements pour l'éducation des
filles les droits me sentais sexuels et
reproductifs la lutte contre les
violences et le soutien aux combattants
de la liberté nous n'oublions aucune
d'elles et chacun de ses combats est
existentiel pour nous
cela nous l'avons fait ensemble ce sont
ces combats que nous continuerons aussi
apporté en suivant la situation en
afghanistan et ailleurs
car ce qu'il s'y passe ce qu'il s'y joue
est essentiel pour nous
se battre pour les droits de l'homme
c'est aider concrètement les pays qui
sont en première ligne en afrique ou en
asie pour accueillir les réfugiés qui
fuient la guerre et les persécutions la
première ministre du bangladesh le sait
pour faire chaque jour à la tragédie
d'héroïne gars mais plusieurs d'entre
vous le savent et ô combien qui vivait
avec des populations déplacées avec des
réfugiés et les crises terroristes les
conséquences de la pandémie les
conséquences des drames climatique que
toutes les régions du globe sont en
train de vivre font que notre planète
aujourd'hui vit l'une des oeuvres les
plus terribles celle précisément où nos
droits sont bafoués chaque jour parce
que des centaines de millions de nos
compatriotes
de citoyens du monde vivent déplacées
réfugiées
privés de leurs droits et dans la
détresse la plus absolue je veux ici
remercier toutes les associations qui se
battent et les combattants ne
l'humanitaire nous leur devons
protection et nous aurons l'occasion en
début d'année prochaine avec le ministre
de tenir dans le cadre de la présidence
française un sommet justement une fois
encore pour nos humanitaire je veux ici
les en remercier solennellement
il se bat plusieurs d'entre vous se
battent plusieurs organisations
internationales
la croix rouge internationale tout
particulièrement et merci de ce combat
mené partout à travers le globe nous
devons continuer l'action humanitaire
nos engagements financiers et c'est un
enjeu essentiel pour la préservation
même de nos droits
se battre pour les droits de l'homme
c'est défendre les droits des enfants
dans les conflits armés mais aussi dans
l'espace numérique où ils sont exposés
chaque jour à d'insoutenables violence
nous évoquerons tout à l'heure cet
agenda est essentielle dans quelques
instants
se battre pour les droits de l'homme
c'est enfin défendre nos libertés toutes
nos libertés face à toutes les formes
d'autoritarisme de totalitarisme ou
d'extrémisme et enfin c'est aussi se
battre pour nos valeurs et nos droits
dans le cadre d'un agenda numérique pour
créer un ordre public du numérique et de
la paix en ligne nous allons dans un
instant y revenir et écouté plusieurs
engagements qui seront pris mais des
sommets take for good
au global par nachi pour l'intelligence
artificielle en passant par le cra est
urgent coll
le pari ce col et toutes les initiatives
conduites durant ces dernières années un
travail important a été mené
pour l'information et la démocratie
aussi avec reporters sans frontières et
plusieurs d'entre vous un agenda
démocratique indispensable
c'est aussi cela se battre pour nos
valeurs
ces engagements que nous avons pris il
ya un an je voulais vous en rendre
compte aujourd'hui pour vous dire tout
ce qui a été fait sur ce chemin depuis
un an malgré la pandémie comme vous le
voyez beaucoup de choses ont avancé et
ont tenu beaucoup de progrès concrets
ont été faits la difficulté
c'est qu'ils ne vont pas assez vite
qu'ils ne sont pas encore assez justes
et qu'il nous faut aussi collectivement
avoir cet esprit de responsabilité d'en
rendre compte de manière régulière pour
pouvoir dire ce qu'ils avancent et ceux
qui ne progresse pas encore suffisamment
et qu'il nous faut relancer les quelques
axes que je viens de données seront pour
ce qui est de la france
le chemin de son action pour les
prochains mois
vous l'avez rappelé
et ça dans votre propos tout à l'heure
je rappelais il ya quatre ans la
différence entre le nationalisme et le
patriotisme
le patriotisme c'est aimer son pays en
ne cherchant pas à s'opposer au reste du
monde
tous ces chemins
toutes ces actions que nous avons à
conduire n'existe que dans la
coopération internationale
elle n'existe que par deux partenariats
nouveaux et une volonté d'être efficace
mais tout cela est aujourd'hui
éminemment fragilisé
par de nouvelles crises de nouveaux
bouleversements
tout cela est aujourd'hui bousculé par
de nouvelles fractures
sécuritaire et géopolitiques qui sont en
train de s'installer
et je voudrais simplement finir mon
propos en ajoutant un engagement à ce
que nous avions pris il nous faut
maintenant adopter ces méthodes du
multilatéralisme efficace pour relancer
un agenda de contrôle des armements de
coopération entre les grandes puissances
et de lutte contre la désorganisation
du monde
car sinon les grands conflits
qui aujourd'hui se préparent les
tensions qui menacent chaque jour d'
escalade viendront retard 10 c'est un
agenda essentiel que je viens d'évoquer
il nous faudra sur le contrôle des armes
sur la construction d'un
multilatéralisme de paix réinventer sur
la gestion des conflits régionaux comme
nous allons demain le fer avec l'union
africaine et les nations unies
sur la libye
bâtir aussi des coalitions nouvelle pour
régler les crises régionales et
construire la paix
vous l'avez compris
depuis un an nous avons fait beaucoup de
choses
mais il nous reste infiniment affaire
alors que tous ceux qui croient au
multilatéralisme efficace et à ce
nouveau consensus de paris s'imagine
être décisif heureux pour ma part je le
suis merci
[Applaudissements]
à